Speaker 1: Here is a sort of portrait in the
childish nature of the modern American right wing.
As many of you know this phrase Let's go, Brandon
has become. Yes, a cringeworthy but a rallying cry
nonetheless for the American A. Biden right wing.
Let's go, Brandon, if you're not familiar with it,
there was a NASCAR driver named Brandon who was
being interviewed after a race and the crowd was
chanting, F Joe Biden. But the reporter doing the
interview heard it as, Let's go Brandon instead of
Joe Biden. It's let, let's go Brandon. So because
it was misheard. Now if you mean if Joe Biden, you
say, Let's go Brandon, they've got flags, they've
got shirts, they've got all sorts of merchandise.
Of course, it's being monetized. It's not a good
right wing meme unless it's being monetized.
Joe Biden and Joe Biden took phone calls from
people over the holiday to say hello and to say,
you know, different things. That was my phone that
dropped and a guy got on the phone with Joe Biden
and he actually said, Let's go Brandon and
Joe Biden, seemingly unaware of the meme,
or at least choosing not to react to it, says,
Yeah, OK, let's let's go Brandon. And the right
is absolutely aroused and titillated by it. They
are foaming at the mouth. They think it's great.
Except now the guy who did it, Jared Smack,
is saying, I was kidding. And it was just
my free speech and now I am being harassed. So
let's go through the different elements of it.
Here is the video of this incident taking
place, and Joe Biden seems to either not care
or not even be aware of the meme.
Speaker 2: This is it to you,
Jared. This is for the kids. That's right.
I hope you have a wonderful Christmas.
Yeah, I hope you guys have a
wonderful Christmas as well. And
let's go, Brandon. Let's go, Brandon. All
great. Hey, by the way, where are you in Oregon?
Where is your home? I think we lost.
Speaker 1: Yeah. OK, so it's very
dumb. I mean, if this is the big wow
payoff, it's a very, very dumb payoff.
But the right loved it. Here is Donald Trump
Jr. saying it's amazing. And Joe Biden doesn't
know what's going on, et cetera, et cetera.
Speaker 2: I mean, who would have thought
Joe Biden just gave guys like me the greatest
Christmas present ever? He has no idea what's
going on, folks, so I'm laughing and we're joking.
And maybe this guy, the guy who yelled out,
But let's go, Brennan. That guy is a hero. Not
all heroes. We're case unless this guy's wearing
a cape, which he should. Absolutely amazing.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So listen, first of all,
if Joe Biden really didn't recognize, like, let's
assume Joe Biden is not doing a poker face here,
let's assume he really doesn't recognize the
meme. I don't care whether presidents are aware
of the memes about them and the jokes and the
insults about them. I really don't care. I care
about policy, and I have many criticisms of Joe
Biden about policy, which I've made on the show.
But I don't care if Joe Biden doesn't know about
this, if he does, and he just kept a poker face,
that's even even funnier. But the
really funny part at the end of the day
is the reaction from the guy who did it.
Jared Schneck, who is the guy that did this,
claims he is, quote, being attacked
for utilizing my freedom of speech
after he essentially told the president to f
himself. The right loves to talk about tone
and demeanor and behaving appropriately. And what
the guy essentially did is tell the president to
to his face to go f himself. If you have respect
for the office, remember under George W. Bush,
or even if you don't agree with the specifics
of going to Iraq, you must respect the office.
It's another one of those values
they don't really care about.
Now he sort of says that he was kidding. He says
it was just a joke. I don't know what the joke
exactly is. And he says it was a reflection
of his frustration with Biden's policies,
including federal vaccine mandates, inflation
and global supply supply chain problems.
When I watched that video, it didn't seem like
when he said, Let's go, Brandon, that's what he
was talking about. Schmidt went on to say, At the
end of the day, I have nothing against Mr. Biden,
but I am frustrated because I think he could be
doing a better job. Schmidt is 35 and is a former
police officer now working for the electrical
company and has, I mean, no disrespect to him.
Saying f you to the president seems disrespectful
if you're talking about respect for the office.
He says. I understand there's a vulgar meaning,
but I'm not that simple minded no matter how I
feel about him. Just unbelievable, unbelievable.
It's it's another one of the oh, he clarified,
he's not a Trumper, but is a freethinking American
and follower of Jesus Christ and says I'm being
attacked for utilizing my freedom of speech. Once
again, freedom of speech doesn't mean freedom
from the consequences of that speech. When you go
and tell the president to his face, to f himself,
there may be people who don't like that,
and that speech might have consequences.
There's no violation of your First Amendment.
The government is not limiting or abridging your
your ability to speak in any way. But
there simply may be consequences. So
this was his big moment. Donald, he got an attaboy
from Donald Trump Jr.. And he's also getting a lot
of people responding and saying, you know, that
was actually pretty lame. Nobody has violated his
ability to speak. In fact, most people never get
the opportunity to say anything to the president.
Jared Schmoke did, and he said, Let's go, Brandon.
Make of it what you will. We have a couple of
actually I have like four or five different things
to tell you about that are upcoming. First of all,
we have sent out dozens of free T-shirts to
viewers. I made the offer a couple of weeks ago.
If you grab a new, full priced yearly membership
on our website before the end of the year,
I will send you a free T-shirt for a
while. Due to the pandemic, we were seeing
major delays in shipping T. The delays seem to
be gone. Dozens of free T-shirts have gone out,
so if you want to take advantage of of getting
a free T-shirt, you can't be an existing
member. This is for new members. You go to join
Patman dot com, you pay the full yearly price,
not monthly. And then after signing up email
info at David Pakman dot com, I will personally
get that T-shirt out to you. Just got to
sign up by the end of the year. Number two
on January 1st, we're going to do a 2022 midterm
kickoff special. It's going to be an insane
membership discount. If you'd like to be notified
about it and to take advantage of it, just get on
my newsletter at David Pakman dot com. That's
number two. Number three, the viewer town hall
is rescheduled for tomorrow. Why we wanted to do
it A couple of weeks ago when I was on the road,
my connection was terrible. We just couldn't make
it happen. So it's rescheduled for tomorrow. 6:00
p.m. Eastern on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
And then lastly, we are also going to be doing the
next or I guess, first for 2022. The David Pakman
Show chess tournament. If you want to play in the
chess tournament, these are great community
events. Everybody's welcome. It's going to be
Tuesday, January 11th at 6:00 p.m. Eastern.
I'll have more about that in the new year,
but you can market on the calendar the next chess
tournament. Tuesday, January 11th 6:00 PM Eastern,
so we'll take a quick break. It's great to
be back and so much to talk with you about.